We have a voicemail number two one nine two
David p with a very interesting question about
improving the democratic debates.
Take a listen to this.
Hi, David was the last Democratic presidential
candidate debate being largely obsessed on
the substantial and showing candidates, positions
and policy.
Aside from the obvious need to reduce participants,
what would you suggest change and the next
debate to improve this?
Maybe there could be better questions asked.
Thanks.
Yeah.
So the, I mean, there's so much that needs
to happen to really improve the quality of
these debates.
Number one, we do need fewer candidates.
That's going to happen by the third debate.
So that is going to take care of itself.
Uh, I think that we need a narrow range of
topics so the debates should really be much
more highly focused.
So that, uh, number one, you can go into more
depth on particular topics and you can actually
follow up and moderators should be following
up with questions in order to really figure
out who knows in depth about these issues.
Because when you have a debate format where
there's 10 people on the stage, uh, not every
candidate even gets answer every question.
The ones that do get only 60 seconds, only
some candidates get to issue a rebuttal.
And the ones that do only get 30 seconds,
it's too easy to skirt by without having to
actually demonstrate that you know, anything
about these issues.
So I would drastically narrow the focus of
each debate, tax policy and inequality and
entire debate on that.
If you have only five or six candidates on
stage, you can actually give them, you know,
several minutes for their initial response
and then give other candidates several minutes
to rebut them, structure it in a way so that
the moderators can participate and actually
ask followup and probing questions without
being accused of, of partisanship or trying
to help one candidate or the other.
Um, everybody should be able to comment on
every question and the topics should be drastically
narrowed so that you have many questions about
one topic and none of this is possible if
the number of participants isn't decreased,
which it will be soon.
Now, will they, will they actually make these
changes?
Probably not because these are what I call,
um, uh, the, the debates are structured to
be sort of argument porn.
That's really the, the role of the moderators.
And, uh, we really learned
very little about the political positions
of our candidates when that's the format.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member or a patron.
I'll speak to you then the David Pakman show@davidpacman.com
[inaudible].